[Music]
[Applause]
i mentioned this last week
you know that we had a rooting interest
you know everybody wanted to see tiger
come back and i said no we are rooting
for harry higgs
and the danette said why said well alex
higgs said he was going to wear a meet
friday t-shirt
and while he caddied for his brother at
augusta and i thought well nobody's
going to see it and then all of a sudden
stuart sink has a hole in one and harry
is playing with stewart sink and i see
alex he opened up his bib and i could
see the meet friday t-shirt i said we
have we have somebody who we can root
for now and uh harry and alex join us
now thank you guys uh they're joining us
from uh south carolina
um who's so when you decided you're
gonna wear the meat friday shirt alex
harry what was your reaction to that did
you have to give approval
uh yeah dan i was all in and uh we
qualified last year for uh this year's
masters in may at the pga with a top
four finish
and if i remember correctly alex in our
celebration which you could imagine was
was long and and appropriate at some
point during that night when we were
celebrating i i believe al mentioned
that he had a meet friday t-shirt and he
was so excited to wear it at augusta so
this is almost a full year um
al you go into specifics about
how augusta
kind of views t-shirts under the uh
we'll call them white tuxedos oh uh did
you get any pushback alex on wearing the
meat
no pushback but there is a large sign in
the little caddy area that says
any outside logos or anything like that
is banned underneath the shirt so when i
rolled in on friday i had a quarter zip
over and i got dressed and i zipped it
all the way up and then obviously
throughout the round it seemed like the
zipper kept falling and falling
it seemed intentional when i saw you
know stuart sink has the hole in one on
16. harry gives him a hug and then all
of a sudden i see you and it it looked
like you uh he had opened it up as much
as you possibly could there
yeah i was uh
i wish i could say that i was doing that
on purpose because i figured i was going
to be on camera i was watching yesterday
and i was like god i wish i could say
that that was on purpose but i was just
i have a compass and i was just trying
to put the compass away and the meat
friday sure just came out
but uh yeah it will go if it was on
purpose it certainly was not but uh yeah
good timing because i didn't hit a
single shot worthy of television all day
friday so
wait you finished 14th though
yeah friday was a tough day it was it
was windy friday and saturday were
brutal saturday was cold it was windy we
were just kind of fighting tooth and
nail just to get it in the house friday
and saturday
but good on good on stuart singh for for
making an ace it was so cool to hear
that roar down there on 16 as well
um and then yeah just all worked out
that that camera did not pan and we
finally it's been almost a year in the
making we finally got the uh me friday
shirt
shown on television at augusta you guys
argue like brothers when you're caddying
absolutely oh yeah absolutely everything
uh and the majority of it's my fault
right i'm the one that that
has la the last say i'm the one that has
the most control uh but i blame out for
everything um you know and then shortly
after around about an hour after around
it there's usually a uh yeah you know
that was just a bad shot or that was my
fault um
the majority of the uh the blame rests
on me but in the moment the easiest
thing to do is just blame your brother
it's a very thankless job yeah it really
is you ever
ever come close to blows
no not yet and i don't think we will i
mean it's a game
um we've had some arguments al every now
and i know it's bad when al uh chirps
back usually my whining and complaining
is met with silence
if al chirps back in
his classic is like what did you just
say to me um i know that i'm in trouble
when when i get that
how much fun do you have playing in the
masters i mean it looks like a lot of
pressure on a very tough golf course and
everybody's watching how much fun is it
sure i mean it's
it's a dream for for both of us really
and it's so cool to share it with your
brother right i mean i've played
this is my third year on tour now i've
played eight some odd years of
professional golf and that was my first
masters um
it's it's our kind of it's the mecca of
golf it's it's
it's the greatest tournament on the
grandest stage
um so it was really just a treat to
share it with my brother and then you
know we've we had some success that was
our second major we're we're doing
really well in these majors um i need to
do a better job of kind of preparing for
we'll call them normal tour events like
we do majors and
it's not it's not that i don't care when
i play normal tour events but something
just gets ratcheted up in the majors and
the focus level gets higher
but augusta i mean augusta's augusta we
we we were lucky enough to get there
early december um me and al and my dad
we played with a member kind of as like
a you know
pseudo practice round
and that's that day will be will be
remembered for
the rest of our lives right to see i
mean one for both of us to see our dad's
reaction who is no good at golf and just
slapped it around the place with a smile
on his face
and then just you know that's a that's a
memory as a family that we'll have
forever um on the on the coolest and
best golf course that that there is in
my opinion
harry and alex higgs harry is the pro
alex is his brother his caddy there uh
hilton head coming up this uh this
weekend
alex at what point do you say
i'll be your caddy
i mean you're what three years younger
than your brother so you're what 27 did
you go to mom and dad and say hey i got
an idea what i want to do with the rest
of my life i'm going to caddy for my
brother
no so i was playing i've been doing it
for two and a half years now i was
playing golf myself professionally and i
wasn't
playing that well and i was kind of
bouncing around between trying to find a
real job playing and then
and then he just asked me to caddy for
him and we've been playing the golf
together since we were
in first grade so
it just kind of felt right i remember
telling my dad you know i was
interviewing for uh just like normal
office jobs or what what not and uh
i told my dad i found a job you know i
got one he goes what are you gonna do
and said i'm in a caddy for harry he
looks at me goes are you kidding me
so it was met with a little resistance
but i think we figured out a good uh
a good recipe for some success did you
guys get to cross paths with tiger do
you
are you like you know kids that you want
to walk up and say hello excuse me mr
woods
so every round every round before
uh at the masters we do a harry and i
and then his coach corey lundberg we do
a toss like we're on the putting green
right before we tee off try to lighten
things up and you toss it if you make it
it's a hundred dollars
and on thursday the first round we just
happened to be on the putting green at
the same time as tiger and his cor his
coach has got a lot of a lot of nerve he
picked the whole tiger was putting to so
all three of us throw these golf balls
at the hole and they go racing by the
hole and tiger just looks over at harry
and goes man nice putt
putting 20 footers you know
18 20 feet by tiger had to think that
that i was terrible
and i tried my best but like no no we we
were throwing them it's our thing we do
it all the time
yeah right right and then he was off and
then i went to the first tee
um that was really all we saw of tiger
and in my three years i haven't i think
we played in probably four or five
events um you know together we haven't
been grouped together or anything
but what a what a feat it was i mean the
man
played the weekend through two rounds
was in contention
um barring scotty running away with the
golf tournament and you know he's
basically doing that on a leg and a half
and hasn't played golf in almost two
years competitively it's
tiger never ceases to amaze it truly is
incredible you uh
have your sponsor there dude wipes
yes yes um
so do you go ahead how often do you
think
exactly what are you thinking
so does alex does alex hand you the dude
wipes
those are only in the most dire
situations yeah okay
we usually can get our
our business taken care of before
uh you know so nothing pops up on the
golf course
uh augusta's nice they got a bunch of
bathrooms hidden all over the place so
if you need you need a little respite
they've got it there for us um it's
always weird hearing the random 50 year
old
i
think we lost the boys maybe the sensors
with the dude wipe story yeah the dude
wipes the first thing fritzy saw he's
like oh he's got a sponsor dude wipes
um well the research was done at that
point uh fritzy tell them thank you and
see if you can get alex's phone number
and we'll send him uh some uh some dp
show gear
that was fun